first thing you want to know is the
surface area of an entire sphere and
remember when you're talking about
surface area or talking about that outer
surface you know the area if you were to
cover this with little 1x1 square
you know patches right how many would
cover that outer surface and the formula
is 4 times pi times the radius squared
but then what we do with the hemisphere
is we go ahead and we cut it in half
right so now what happens when you go to
cut this in half is this surface right
here okay is going to be 2 PI R squared
because half of 4 PI R squared but in
the process of cutting it in half we
expose this bottom circle here so when
you're cutting it like in half like this
now if you were to pick this up okay and
look at that part right there you can
see it's going to be a circle and you
that's also now becoming the outer
surface that we know the area of a
circle is PI R squared or you can think
of it as 1 PI R squared so if you add
these together a hemisphere the surface
area is actually 3 PI R squared so
sometimes students mistakenly say 2 PI R
squared we want 3 PI R squared so a
quick example is if they give you the
radius is 5 real simple you just put
that in for the radius it's going to be
3 times pi times 5 squared that's 25
times 3 which is 75 PI units squared
whatever the units are it's square units
so I hope this helped you understand how
to work with hemispheres a little bit
better if you're interested in online
tutoring with me feel free to contact me
about that otherwise subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
seeing you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon